foreign
Leo in Fresno California starts us off
hi Leo how are you
hi um and Jade how are you doing good
how can we help
hey
um so for
[Music]
your background I
um I'm encountering the situation where
I don't know what to do or how to detach
from it
um I've been a full provider for a
really long time and I was a single mom
for a very long time and
um I've been in the banking industry for
more than 60 years so it's basically all
I know I'm new to the Dave and Ramsey uh
podcast and so my question is their
values and morals no longer align with
what I feel
um brings fulfillment to my life so
um because this is all I know
I'm I don't know how to detach or let go
or how to even navigate this this new
season of my life so
I was hoping I could get some
orientation in a sense so what's an
example of can you give me an example of
how it doesn't line up I think I know
what you mean but just for clarity's
sake so so Jade um
you know you're you're in a sales like
environment where
um you basically
uh
encourage and you know incentivize
people to get in debt right okay okay
and
and I no longer find right that to be
a part of who I want to be anymore so
have you started looking for other
opportunities other job opportunities
that are not uh requiring you to do debt
sales
um I have however I have not been very
successful I think I've had one or two
interviews
um
you know within Wells Health Fargo is
what I call it
um and so um
I I haven't had any luck well I think
you just got to keep going out there I
think you got to get clear about what
what it is that you want to do from this
point on because like you said that
industry was all that you knew so you're
finding now that your values don't align
with that so now it's time to start
painting the picture of what your values
do align with and what it is that you
want to do long term and start looking
for those opportunities and it probably
is going to take you applying for more
than just one or two jobs you're
probably gonna have to really put
yourself out there you know and and keep
throwing your net out completely Leo how
old are you
I am 35 and what do you make
around 80 a year my husband makes around
140. okay
um can you live on 140
for six months
yeah that's what he actually suggests
yeah um I'm not saying you had to I'm
just saying if you accept that
emotionally and swallow that it gives
you a lot of peace
because now you're just staying in the
bank until you find something uh and you
don't feel as trapped
you're not trying I feel trapped right
you're not you're not trapped your
husband's right you could quit today and
take six months to wander around doing
something you'll find something to do
okay what do you do what do you actually
do at the bank what is your title I'm a
business
um that's perfect so that sets you up
those are transferable skills to do
business relationships in other
businesses
other businesses that want to interact
in what we call B2B business to business
transactions would find your skill set
of having formerly worked at the bank
very valuable
but you're not any more trapped than you
the only reason you're traps you feel
like you are you've got very
transferable skills your husband makes
enough money for y'all to live on until
you make the move
so you're not trapped but I wouldn't
quit I would just go on a very uh let's
pretend that if you don't get a job in
four months that you will get a terminal
illness let's use that kind of
motivation
okay okay just go in other words what
would you do if you said if I don't have
a new job in four months I'm gonna die
well then you would go get a new job
mm-hmm you would you wouldn't talk to
three people you talk to 300 right
because how how much time up until this
point Leo how much time have you put
into your job search let's just talk to
three people I mean yeah
yeah you're just gonna have to do more
you're playing with it and you're
rehearsing this as you drive to work mad
at yourself stop feeling stuck and
you're rehearsing it over and over and
over in your head I want you to rehearse
it in front of human beings and get a
new job
so I'm gonna send you Ken Coleman's book
from paycheck to purpose I'm going to
send you his uh assessment
which is his career assessment take that
takes 27 minutes to take it I'm going to
give it all to you for free and I'm
going to give you his other number one
bestseller proximity principle which
will help you land the job if I give you
all of that will you read those two
books and go interview to 22 people in
the next three days
I'm kidding in the next 30 days in the
next 30 days okay well you do it
immediately with some urgency
I I will I want some Swagger girl yeah I
want you Swagger
I want to see you strut up that sidewalk
not walk up with your head down going
I'm not worthy
yeah
make eight grand a year you're not done
dumb people don't make 80 grand
well maybe a few I'm not sure I was
gonna say Dave maybe just a few oh my
gosh but I'm serious I mean you have a
lot you're giving yourself a credit of a
two out of 100 and I'm giving you a
credit for 102 out of 100. yeah I think
she was thinking she could just kind of
like tap her toe in the water and maybe
something magical would happen but
you've gotta you can't find Godmother's
not coming you're the secret sauce kiddo
get out there get after it yeah get
after it that's how you do it hang on
we're gonna give you those two books and
that career assessment and help you get
started on this we want you to be able
to win